let me tell you another thing it is
never been less valuable to be smart
about information than today it has
never been less valuable
who's the 19th president oh I don't know
this guy right every in every piece of
information this is a very important
point a lot of people made a lot of
money a lot of people made a lot of
relationships a lot of people have
leverage within their circles about
being informational smart that has been
completely wiped out
it actually has zero value and so which
is why it's insane what our children are
going through in the school system
making them memorize facts that are at
their fingertips
[ __ ] yeah it kills me kills me and so I
hope my children BDNF students and that
gives me time since they're not gonna
work on homework for me to teach them
the real [ __ ] yes right and so you know
I think we're living again I keep
repeating in this interview we're living
this is the Internet is the biggest
culture shift in the history of human
beings we're living through it so we
can't contextualize it but we are
grossly under estimating what's
happening